the war in ukraine and new images this
morning showing the brutality of
russia's aggression there a warning
you've heard it before these are
disturbing images we really mean it the
attack you're about to look at happened
at a train station in the town of crema
torsk that's in eastern ukraine near the
front lines where the fighting has been
most intense
so take a look this is the aftermath of
a rocket strike where local ukrainian
officials say at least 39 people were
killed more than 80 wounded you see bags
scattered around on the ground because
many people here were trying to flee the
fighting there's also new evidence of
horrific crimes in suburbs around keefe
russia has now left the area after a
terrifying occupation the kremlin is
admitting its forces have suffered
significant losses in battles with the
ukrainian military holly williams is in
a suburb aboard the yonka ali good
morning
good morning the russian forces that
came through borodianco killed they
destroyed homes and residents say they
loot it but what they didn't do was come
close to their apparent objective
seizing control of ukraine's capital
kiev and it makes what they inflicted on
this town look even more futile we want
to warn you that our report contains
some disturbing images
the russian soldiers have gone now in
borodian rescue teams are searching for
bodies beneath the rubble they left
behind they say they found 26 here
yesterday
my goodness elena guyevka showed us what
was her home now shattered she and her
husband petro came back to collect the
only things they can their treasured
family photos
ukrainian prosecutors have been to
borodianca to document possible war
crimes in the kiev region we found
650 dead bodies from them it is 40
dead bodies only kids
in kramertorsk this morning ukraine says
more than 30 people were killed by a
russian rocket attack at this train
station that's being used to evacuate
civilians from eastern ukraine their
bodies left crumpled beside their
suitcases
but this video has also emerged
apparently showing a ukrainian fighter
shooting a wounded russian soldier
another seems to have been shot with his
hands tied behind his back
ukraine says it will investigate in
stark contrast to russia which claims
videos of massacred civilians were
somehow staged
in the nearby village of turmeric
they told us the russian soldiers looted
everything from clothing and silverware
to refrigerators and washing machines
the head of the village nicola olexienko
showed us their clinic hypodermic
needles
medication which he said the russians
raided leaving it wrecked so it sounds
like they came here hoping to treat
themselves for their injuries
russia's invasion of ukraine appears not
just brutal but incompetent and
unprofessional
termakivka is around 30 miles from the
chernobyl nuclear site where russian
troops have also pulled out leaving more
senseless destruction ukraine says the
russians dug these trenches in one of
the most contaminated parts of the
exclusion zone
exposing themselves to significant doses
of radiation
the reason i'm wearing this body armor
today is not because there are russian
forces anywhere near here but because we
believe there's a lot of unexploded
ammunition here in borodianka and as
they sift through the rubble it could be
lethal the local residents don't have
this protection
gail
it's always very very dangerous there
holly williams thank you in boro dianca